yesterday we talked on the podcast
about how at this early stage i mean
listen it's not even an early stage
we're not even at the 2024 primary
season we're not even beyond the 2022
primaries
there have been some republicans that
are already endorsing donald trump jim
jordan for example
um we have also seen some republicans
declare
they will not support donald trump even
if he does run
this is starting to get even weirder
because donald trump has now signaled
that he is running in 2024 in a bizarre
truth social post in which he referred
to himself
as the future president of the united
states seems very clearly to be saying
i'm running let's review this bizarre
post trump writing quote
why would a future president of the
united states want to have
candidate-important conversations with
his white house counsel if he thought
there was even a small chance that this
person essentially acting as a lawyer
for the country
may someday be brought before a partisan
and openly hostile committee in congress
or even a fair and reasonable committee
to reveal the inner secrets of foreign
policy or other important matters so bad
for the usa
trump really a legend in his own mind so
what is he talking about i know you
might see this and say that's like a
verbal inkblot that what is that
trump is referring to his former white
house counsel pat sipoloni which i last
week was pronouncing chipoloni people
very politely corrected me and they said
it is actually uh only pronounced
sippiloney no more drachma exactly we
all make
we all make mistakes so trump here is
saying listen
uh
this was the
lawyer for the country
but that is a fundamental
misunderstanding the white house counsel
is the president's lawyer now in an
ideal world the president's interests
are aligned with the country's interests
in particular when donald trump was
president
the country's interests and trump
interests were completely at odds they
were not in any way aligned and so the
idea that pat sipoloni by representing
president trump is representing the
interests of the country is nonsense now
the other thing is that
he wasn't having the conversation so he
says
as if me as a future president
i'm disincentivized from talking to my
lawyer if i think my lawyer might
someday be dragged before a committee
trump's conversations with sipoloni when
trump was president
were not conversations as a future
president if that was the case you might
be able to make a stronger argument that
they are protected by attorney-client
privilege cipolloni can't be forced to
testify we wouldn't even be having this
discussion trump was the president
sipoloni represented him they were
actively engaged in inciting a riot
trying to overturn an election trump
lost all these different things and of
course sipoloni's testament testimony
would be eminently reasonable and
relevant and it's supposedly going to be
happening behind closed doors sipoloni
today
scheduled to be speaking to the house
committee whether it happens we will we
will figure that out now uh for one
moment i thought did trump mean as a
future prisoner rather than as a future
president that's wishful thinking i
don't expect that to happen now a few
hours later just to kind of close the
circle on this insanity
trump added some other strange comments
in subsequent posts also related to the
investigations into him writing quote
both of my phone calls to georgia were
perfect now of course those were the
calls where trump asked for votes i need
11 000 votes give me a break trump going
on and saying i had an absolute right to
make them and in fact the story on the
one call was given a retraction or
apology by the washington post because
they were given terribly false
information about it now that's not true
and when they heard the actual call they
realized their story was wrong
thank you to the washington post i as
does anyone else just look at the
democrats have the absolute right to
challenge the results of an election
this one corrupt rigged and stolen
continuing saying quote i did nothing
wrong in georgia but others did they
cheated in the 2020 presidential
election and those are the ones that
should be investigated and prosecuted
letter to follow and i have not seen the
letter that supposedly follows this is a
desperate
unhinged man
clawing any relevance that he can obtain
and of course it's always the opposite
for six months he said the democrats are
going to try to steal the election
he tried to steal the election for
months he said the democrats are going
to mess with these ballots
dumps of ballots and mail-in ballots and
ultimately it was trump and his
followers and his lawyers going around
the country making bogus claims about
those very mail-in ballots the
allegations are ultimately confessions
with these guys we've got to be ready
for 2022 and we've got to be ready for
2024. will we be ready that's the
question let me know what you think find
me on twitter at dpakman
science has shown us that lowering your
body temperature at night improves sleep
in many ways our sponsor chilly sleep
creates systems that cool down your bed
promoting deeper higher quality sleep it
also just feels great i use it at home
i'd recommend it to anyone and i've
recommended it to some friends who now
use it as well
chili sleeps product the uhler the cube
and the doc pro
they're all water-based temperature
controlled pads that fit onto your
existing mattress you can keep your bed
as low as 55 degrees as hot as 115
degrees i like 60 their new doc pro
sleep system has double the cooling
power of other models five times the
cooling contact whisper quiet you can
control it with your phone it's awesome
with chilly sleep there's no more
feeling hot at night no more sweating
cooling your bed down like this is
amazing you really have to try it for
yourself when you go to chilisleep.com
pacman you'll get thirty percent off of
the uhler and cube sleep systems and ten
percent off the new doc pro this offer
is only for my audience the link is down
below